In this section, we will continue with the remainder of the steps for the final fitting process.
First, we will look at best practices for positioning the eye geometry and capturing the eye gaze.
We will then look at how to approach manipulating the tear duct region polygons of the head mesh and all the additional assets.
We will also go through the steps for preparing the body skeleton Maya file that is needed before DNA calibration is used.
So let's resume with the final fitting process by looking at how to position the eye geometry.
Since the majority of the additional assets are fitted to the eye region, it is important to position the eyes first.
The clean copy of the eyes should be positioned while using the wrapped eyes as a reference.
When positioning the eyes, ensure the eye gaze is correct.
You can use the pupil and iris textures as a reference.
Combine the sclera and iris textures which are located in the metahuman face textures folder in Unreal Engine with the iUV coordinates texture for Maya.
On the UV coordinates texture, the fifth loop is where the iris should be.
Once the eyes have been positioned and the eye gaze is correct, the next step is to inspect and adjust the tear duct region of the head geometry.
The tear duct region is where the inner eye edge of the eyelid and the eyeball geometry make contact.
We can see the precise location in the animated GIF.
If the polygon flow around the eye region has deviated, the vertices may need to be manually moved and repositioned.
Use the head LOD2 to make adjustments and ensure all the edges and loops correspond to a standard LOD0 preset metahuman, especially when manipulating polygons in high density areas.
Once the eye region of the head mesh has been manually adjusted, the additional assets can be fitted vertex by vertex.
In the images on this slide, we can see what each of the geometry assets look like before and after the fitting process.
For the head mesh, ensure the tear duct region is correct.
For the eye edge, it should fit the eye geometry.
The cartilage should fit around the eyelids and lacrimal interior.
The eye edge should be concave and not overlap with the eyeball geometry, and the eyelashes should be within the cartilage area.
Once everything has been fitted, correctly name and export the geometry assets individually as OBJ files.
With the fitted geometry ready to be used with DNA calibration, the final asset that will be needed is the prepared body skeleton Maya file.
Let's jump into Maya and go through the steps of preparing this asset.
Inside of Maya, I will be demonstrating how to prepare the body skeleton Maya file, and I will be using a portion of the Unreal Fest scaling script for this.
We will be going over DNA calibration in the next section, so don't worry, we will go through how to set this up and use it later on.
Over here, I've opened up the script editor.
In the file explorer, I have the Unreal Fest folder open.
The scaling script is located in the script folder and it is named UFScale.
I copied the contents of the script and pasted it in a new Python window that I created by using this plus sign and selected Python.
To use this script, for the root directory, point it to the location of the DNA calibration folder, which in my case is my C drive.
I have changed the backward slash to a forward slash.
The work directory is pointed to the location of the Unreal Fest folder, which is on my D drive.
Now to prepare the body skeleton Maya file, the first step is to open up the body rig Maya file of the character you are using.
I have opened up the Maya scene for the female short underweight body rig.
The second step is to delete the geometry and driver skeleton.
I'm going to select the geometry and delete this.
Next, I will select the driver skeleton and delete this.
The third step is to unconstrained the skeleton.
One way to do this is to use a portion of the Unreal Fest DNA calibration scale script.
As mentioned, we will be going over how to use DNA calibration later, but for now I will be showing what command you can run to unconstrained the skeleton.
I'm going to select the root.
Inside of the script editor, I will select the first portion of the script and initialize it by right clicking on it and selecting execute.
Now that this is in memory, I'm going to make sure that the root is selected and I will scroll down here to step three, where it says scale body and unbind driver skeleton.
And I will select this portion here from line 44 to 46, then right click and select execute to unconstrained the skeleton.
The third step is to delete joints that are not needed.
I will delete the skeleton and unhide the root.
The next step is to collapse this and delete the legs and lower arms.
We do not need the thighs, so I will select these and delete them.
We also do not need the lower arms, so I will collapse the spine and then the clavicles and the upper arms.
I'm going to select the left lower arm and lower arm twists and then the right lower arm and lower arm twists and delete these.
And this is what is needed for the prepared body skeleton Maya file that will be used with DNA calibration.
The last step is to save the scene and rename it however you wish.
Now let's do a quick review of the steps we just covered before we move on.
The body skeleton Maya scene is needed when using DNA calibration to export the head LODs as FBX.
The workflow for preparing the body skeleton Maya file was showcased step by step in the 2023 Unreal Fest DNA calibration deep dive.
And the link to the presentation can be found in the resources slide of this course.
To summarize the workflow, begin by going to the source assets folder of your character and locate the body rig Maya scene that has your character's body proportion.
From there, the first step is to delete the geometry and driver skeleton.
Then select the root and break the constraints. You can use the Unreal Fest scaling script to do this.
Paste the entire script into the script editor, initialize the first portion of the script and then run step 3 with the root selected.
Then unhide the root and then delete the legs and the lower arms and lower arm twists joints.
The last step is to save the scene and rename it however you wish.
Now with the fitted geometry OBJ files and body skeleton Maya scene, we are ready to use these with DNA calibration.
In the next portion of our course, we will delve into setting up the DNA calibration repository.